hey guys how's it going guess where we
are go ahead I'll look I'll gonna give
you a second hit pause
leave a comment guess where we are okay
great now that you did that we're going
to the trampoline park we are ready to
jump baby what's wrong I just realized
it now as I was running to the car that
my lower back is hiked kind of injured I
don't think I dragged it hurt I needed
her injured you you're sore yeah
that was that was like from prior
injuries yeah where hopefully today will
be okay my arm may start hurting but I
think we'll be fine
I solvent on a backflip I need to work
on the front flip it I'm scared a little
scare and spot you okay and you'll get
it just fine I promise you're gonna be
like oh cheese is so easy I can see
exactly where I'm gonna land versus the
front clip where you just whip around
you're like oh god I'm on my feet now
alright well here goes let's let's go
it up so the park closes at 9:00
and Matt is running so fast because he
was determined to get in here before
seven o'clock I hope there aren't that
many people like
go to bed yeah for school 702 we have a
problem
everyone's injured yeah I didn't feel
this until I just started jumping but my
rib cage is just dead and I don't know
why I'm just feeling really weak and
tired so I actually have had a problem
with my lower back ever since I was a
kid and apparently the trampolines have
reacted cuz I'm good
oh I think I've had like some type of
brain injury this is for wha
hey good job
your side thank you a little bit so Matt
is gonna give us the best tutorial the
way that I learned how to do a back flip
is I promise you it is so much using a
front flip it really is the only thing
you need to get over is the act of going
backwards but your body naturally wants
to go backwards yeah I think this
tutorial isn't very good it's hot I'm
just going to do it
that's our tutorial over you see it good
I'm gonna do it one more it's gonna be a
little it's gonna really talk I'm really
tucking and you don't want to be going
forward like he is that's not a good way
to start
okay I just met you so here's my number
so text me baby
should we try backless oh god maybe no
in the pit you want you go first
okay charge your arms up yeah send them
back over your head okay jump backwards
and just look back with your head
Justine back at it that is a great
instructional presentation by Jordan
yeah personally I think you should do it
on the slanted wall oh just that just
just do that just do that guys just do
that oh yeah that was good good I like
that
hello
to jump and go on your back that's all
that wasn't that bad
No
Oh
you pay me nervous do you wanna try I
don't know yes maybe you're you are a
hard body so Wow my god unbelievable oh
that's really great dude hey what it was
funny about that she's right I did
that's amazing
I did it back up once like into a bit
like this like 10 years ago I was in
college like you want to go for it again
no no never again
oh okay it was so scary I made it and
then like I did it again like once like
10 years ago and that did it again and I
like hit my shoulder I was like never
you know it's really scary like yeah cuz
you can still make it like you're not
guy like get seriously Android but you
can like to think you're like spine or
joints that's what I'm concerned about
you have to do it now okay I will well I
promise we're good
whoa Matt what for
I'm worthless now it is your turn dusty
oh my god I'm kidding he's got it just
erased your mom well did you think about
it a little bit
the natural that
do not invite a lady yeah
I feel super defeated yeah I just I
don't know Jordan I don't know why I
said it's okay like the hardest part is
going back and you got that just fire
you just have to get your trajectory
more up rather than dangerous all right
we out we out really is a charge and
then freakin charge it are you turning
or you're not charging I'm not sure if
this is user error